i'm not just saying this because we're
on the show but watching him yesterday
first of all he had a purple tie that i
was like yo that's a pretty pimp
but secondly i was like yo man this dude
just he doesn't do this all the time
anymore and it's just like
fall riding a bike he's and i'm not and
i know for a fact he wasn't paying
attention to
any of those sports and yet he's reading
the stuff he's on it and i'm just like
all right yeah that's what we just got
your name on the rich like he's not
listening
rich what's up man hey rich
hello guys
he's here oh why somebody tell me where
she was on the phone
yes indeed hi honey here how are you
doing
we just had a blackout a surge in the
studio and and
guess what we're here we're back i'm
glad you're back
i don't understand um if you don't mind
me just starting off here
by i don't understand why tom pellicero
is on the show because mike
aren't you plugged in with what's going
on with the shareholders
aren't you like locked in with
your fellow owners as to what's on the
agenda like why do we need a reporter to
call in about
what's happening well you heard what you
heard what chris reported i
as soon as the the meeting started i got
up and i yelled uh quote the with the
question
he doesn't throw a touchdown i mean he
doesn't throw a touchdown you know
that's right
i said i got muted right after that they
blocked me on the zoom
oh i got it i understand so i tried rich
hey which which you know how i feel
about it when you go after mike deltofo
i mean
you know how i feel like i know keep it
keep it civil please he's my old friend
here
no i understand that um but i'm i'm
eager to find out
you know um you know who if if the board
of electors that got elected today
are the people that del tufo saw in his
um his ballot you sent in your ballot
right yes but i
haven't seen who's on the board yet i
need to see the uh
i can do it i'm working rich rich
rich you would have seen me during the
power surge thing
you would have been very proud he was on
fire i mean hoskins were
working this is when this is when you're
at your finest
i'm glad that we had you on that wall
yes i'm glad we had you on that wall
and also rich mike will mike will get
the job done and
he will also let you know that he's
getting the job done
you got to pat yourself on the back i
mean who's not your biggest
yeah it's a good thing t didn't have a
generator but whatever
so uh so rich tell us about your
highlights today on tokyo gold
you said you have you had like a 37
minute archery highlight how'd that go
i don't know why i love the archery i i
don't i don't know why but
um you know today's archery highlight
was intense
um we had the the united states um
getting sent uh home the three-man team
sent home
and then the south koreans and the
japanese
i did not know this that when there's a
tie
what do you do when there's a tie at the
end of the round and you've gone through
the shootouts and there's a tie
i did not know that it's closest to the
bull's eye
um that was new to me that that they
basically take everyone's shots and
whoever's got a shot closest to the
bullseye wins
and uh as i pointed out that probably
also got them a golf bag i think that's
how you got a golf bag in a golf
tournament once chris yeah no
absolutely you know so they got a golf
bag
and then you know a gold medal match
against chinese taipei and
you know uh the video was just put out
on our friends at peacock right now it's
it's it's a stirring finish
three consecutive bullseyes and then a
bullseye to win it
um they they they almost choose the
almost grand video at the end um
that of me off you know on camera but
you know off camera that they shot me
they they took the iso
camera of me doing the highlight and
apparently i
i got up out of the chair uh when that
third bulldog
so you know i mean you just it's you're
feeling it
i got lost in the moment so does it feel
like
sportscenter back in the day because
when i watched you the first one
i i had weird deja vu well you know i i
texted you before we went on the air
that first
day and i'm like you know i feel like
i'm back in a time machine
and then you even gave me you texted
this is when i knew it was working
guys is that when i dropped the line
or i i think it was um
kalish uh in the four by 100
uh individual uh medley
that um his best his best um
his best stroke was the breaststroke and
i called him a breaststroke man
i knew it was working when i get a text
from my wife from susie saying
did you just call somebody a
breaststroker
like yes we're back yes i did
you know so it's it is kind of like that
you know it it
it's it's like i know what you said tj
it it
it's kind of like um riding a bike
you know going back in the highlight
machine and i just
i love it like today's first block of
tokyo gold was 20 minutes long and we
had
swimming gymnastics um
we had uh archery we had um
and then uh the triathlon which was
can you imagine this like so you you
know you've got to
obviously swim bike and run which is
nice yeah
and and triathletes are on your marks to
get
started with the swim being first you
have to swim a mile
and then you've got to bike i think 24
miles
and then run six miles yeah that's
insane no thank you
awful awful so this is so this
so they started though but the tv boat
you know the boat with the tv camera so
you can get a tight shot of everyone
jumping in the water yeah
they were they they were misplaced and
they started the race while the boat was
trying to get out of the way and half
the swimmers couldn't jump in
and the other half jumped in and so like
you know you train your whole life or
you were prepared for last year and then
obviously cobit pushes it this year and
this is your moment
this is it and you're on the line and
you're thinking are they gonna move the
boat
rich i offered my services out of the
way they didn't accept me
i was gonna drive the boat they wouldn't
let me they won't let me
by the way tj had to take his glasses
off and wipe his eyes when you said
skeet
and just saying
i'll tell you it's honest that the tv
boat as it was driving away i did get to
see the the uh the back of it it did say
two pump jump on it
i got it from you mike i just thought
like that's really hard
olympics i lobbed it at you rich
rich what name when you see a shot sheet
coming
what name so far has made your stomach
drop
all of them about right i mean all of
them
and you know we're they're being spelled
phonetically and
um you know it's just but it's been so
much
fun i mean it's just a blast and
you know just being back in the old
highlights and
um machine and and the crew you know
it's the first time everyone's working
together
and we're getting better each show and
everyone seems to be
really um enjoying it and it's so cool i
just instagrammed out a photo
of you sue's at the desk where you are
and me at the desk where i'm re-airing
right now and
it's just so cool that you know that
you're hosting and i'm hosting and it's
a family affair on peacock and
i love it it's phenomenal yeah we have
had fun watching on peacock and tokyo
gold is a blast to watch but
like i said to the guys i mean those
highlights when you i i'm
sweating watching you get through those
highlights i mean obviously i have a
vested interest but just as a viewer
and knowing that you haven't seen these
ahead of time right
i i'm sweating well some of them i'm i'm
definitely
looking over and tj you should know this
you should know this
that the archery the first archery
highlight i did
um peacock put on tick-tock
and it got over a million views so
watch out the x-man was kind of right
like there's a platform there's a
platform on tip top
and um you know i'm just just throwing
it out there
there's people there's i'm a tick top
star he's basically
hey hey rich we've seen you uh do the
archery stuff that was so fun
what sport have you kind of been like oh
this is
actually amazing like what's kind of
taken you by surprise oh gosh like
um handball has been unbelievable like i
didn't know
you know some of these rules and
handball um even you know how you could
take three steps which i i said just
like the nba
and um you know uh that's been pretty
cool
uh rugby is just getting started
interrupted
uh the uh us uh kenya match
kenya looked like kenya had uh scored
but the us punched the ball out before
he hit the ground
wait so through the end zone
[Laughter]
are you gonna try to change that rule
too they didn't catch it because it
appears that you have to
maintain control all the way to the
ground like
literally that happened in rugby today
and they took the
points off the board like that happened
so you know it was was it dez was dez
playing yeah
oh and oh but the best moment of the day
um the best moment of the day was
the uh art was it she's from argentina
yes
argentinian fencer she loses
and she's in her post-match interview
and her coach who's been a partner of 17
years holds up a sign behind her while
she's doing it
saying skinny i guess that's her
nickname will you
marry me wow proposed
gets down on a knee and i'm told
that he tried this 11 years ago and she
said no
oh what he tried again
shoot your shot right that takes some
serious cojones
what's she saying i mean but uh
i guess there was some hold on a minute
mending fencers thank you
god
you went off the clock yes why even
though you're off the clock
but she said yes this time oh okay okay
that was actually an olympic moment that
made our show
today as well so you're saying that was
tokyo gold
oh i don't know
it might be uh diamonds tokyo diamond
yeah you know
do you realize that those skateboarders
those girls are a year older
than or not even they're like three
weeks older than xander i mean these
girls are 13 rich there were two 13 year
olds it was the youngest
um aggregate age of average age of uh of
a podium all three of them together
averaged
14 years and 191 days yeah
crazy unreal that was great i mean and
so we're having fun table tennis is
intense
you know but nothing beats the archery i
mean you know you're just staring down
and you're firing away and i had no idea
that there's closest to the bullseye
no idea that they're they can go back
and stare down and say like
they put the score up with an asterisk
next to it which is like put a pin in it
we'll check it out later sort of like a
whether it's a two or
three and they check it out during the
commercial break and i mean we're i'm
learning a lot
they have like a sky judge for archery
rich yes
i think they might i mean they might i
did ask for pereira during the rugby
highlights
so can you do me a favor he might be
like like just
actually you know it's terry mccauley
for india right
but i haven't heard yet do me a favor
for when you call in tomorrow with your
tokyo gold report
on peacock can you find out why the
table tennis guys serve the way they do
yeah yeah it's really weird what's
happening there
i know they kind of like what like
bounce it like little little bounces or
stuff like that off their ear
but they they it's like they're servers
in a restaurant they're kind of just
like here and then it's like
what is happening i will you know what
i'm on it
i'm on it we will cover aaron rodgers if
you can
figure out what they are doing because
when tj eventually gets his
his pool table from the price is right
we're going to play that in here yeah
right oh yeah absolutely i like it with
the popcorn machine when aaron rodgers
apparently comes back to the class
anyway after all of this so we'll see
how that works and just in the same way
that taylor watches drawing tutorials
chris is going to watch a tutorial on
how to serve and he's going to have to
serve
he's going to pull up pull a hamstring
or maybe tweak it because i'm going to
own you guys once i figure this serve
out it's going to be amazing okay
i love it all right rich thanks hey see
buddy yes yes
[Laughter]
wait wait wait wait wait oh we missed
him
hey rich nah just kidding thanks rich
thanks so much for calling in thanks
rich
chat tomorrow call you later hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here